besser strikt das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat heute die
maßnahmen die es gegeben hat bei der
bekämpfung des virus bestätigt brauchen
wir weiterhin diese maßnahmen
prinzipiell sind wir natürlich in einer
angespannten lage im moment wir haben
hohe infektionszahlen wir haben
angespannte situation auf eine
intensivstation und deswegen brauchen
wir auch in einigen regionen maßnahmen
ich finde es aber wichtig dass wir das
auch regional differenziert vorgehen
weil wir sehen schon deutliche
unterschiede im moment im
infektionsgeschehen zum beispiel mit
erschreckend hohen fallzahlen in sachsen
und bayern mit relativ im vergleich
entspannteren fallzahlen in schleswig
holstein ist es auch eindeutig dass
hamburg mit einer der höchsten
impfquoten in deutschland und schleswig
holstein mit niedrigen fallzahlen dass
sie gar nicht solche maßnahmen brauchen
wie in bayern da ist ein differenziertes
vorgegeben nach eskalationsstufen
eigentlich das richtige für diesen
herbst und winter heißt das aber auch
aus ihrer sicht wir müssen eigentlich
wirklich über eine impfpflicht
nachdenken man muss schon deutlich sagen
dass wenn alle menschen geimpft wären
wäre dieser winter für uns sehr viel
entspannter werden die
intensivmedizinische mediziner nicht so
überlastet und wir werden insgesamt
würden wir besser durch diese welle
kommen und daher kann man nur dafür
plädieren dass sich natürlich alle
menschen impfen lassen ich glaube aber
eine impfpflicht hat einige punkte die
man da benennen muss die auch uns zum
nachteil gereicht werden können zum
einen liegen wir um einen impfstoff wo
wir die schutzdauer und schutzwirkung
noch nicht genau überblicken können also
wir können auch nach der dritten booster
impfung nicht sagen es sind drei
impfungen und danach ist man leben lang
geschützt anders ist das beim packen
gewesen oder bei der masernimpfung
masern zwei impfungen und dann einen
lebenslang geschützt vor dem masern und
dass man ist dann auch wirklich
geschützt und man kriegt eine
herdenimmunität hier haben wir ein virus
wo sich auch ein geimpfter immer mal
infizieren kann und auch an einen nicht
geimpften oder einen anderen kämpfen
weitergeben kann wir haben auch von der
stiko immer mal ändernde empfehlungen
rufen sollte in so einer situation dann
über eine impfpflicht zu reden ist muss
man natürlich dann kritisch betrachten
weil wir eben nicht sagen können ist es
eine impfpflicht jetzt alle sechs monate
oder ist es eine temporäre impfpflicht
jetzt nur für diesen winter also da sind
sehr viele
unsicherheiten weswegen ich glaube dass
uns eine impfpflicht im moment nicht
weiterhelfen kann moralische pflicht das
kann ich schon sehr gut verstehen jetzt
befinden wir uns mitten in der
sogenannten vierten welle und dann kommt
auch noch ein omikron virus eine
mutation wie schlimm ist dass für diese
vierte welle für unsere situation in der
wir sind schauen sie dass wir können zur
nikon noch ganz wenig sagen und das muss
man vielleicht auch mal akzeptieren dass
die wissenschaft nicht ganz so schnell
ist dass sie auf alles dann eine antwort
hat was hier im moment haben als fakten
ist das ja ein virus haben was
unheimlich viele mutationen zeigt also
über 80 mutationen im gesamten genom
32 davon allein im oberflächenprotein
den spike protein von diesen mutationen
können wir virologen natürlich
rückschlüsse ziehen was das bedeutet
aber wir können nicht sagen ob dieses
virus in der tat auch diese
eigenschaften hat das muss jetzt im
nachgang erst noch erforscht werden was
und sie sind ja in einem gremium würden
sie der politik jetzt in diesem
augenblick empfehlen nun ist es erstmal
richtig dass wir versuchen omikron
soweit erst mal zu kontrollieren und
auch nachvollziehen zu können bisher es
aus der wissenschaft besser einschätzen
können daher kann ich auch verstehen
dass man erst mal mehr menschen aus
südafrika zurück kommen dass man sagt ja
wir haben hier eine strengere isolierung
oder quarantäne pflicht um einfach
sicher zu gehen dass ja nicht mit einem
mal von einem neuen virus überrannt
werden